So for our verbs we have amos in the present for we.
Now for er verbs we have emos for the we and for ear verbs we have emos
This is the only time in the whole language that we find a difference between er and ir verbs.
The one group
But here, and it's the only time in the entire language, we have a difference between the two of them in the present for we.
For er verbs we have emos, and for er verbs we have emos.
So preferir what do you think that means preferir?
Prefer.
Good.
To prefer.
We want to think with the two.
Whenever the verb ends in an a, it's gonna help us just to think of that as two.
to prefer preferir.
So how would you say I prefer?
Prefero?
Good, it should be prefero.
Prefiero.
It splits.
He prefers
Prefere.
Prefiere.
They are you plural?
Preferen.
Good.
How would you say we prefer and prefere has an ear ending?
Preferimos.
So there the air doesn't split and also the I of ear is appearing in the endings for the first time in the present tense.
Good.
What was to come?
Had something to do with convenient when things with come
Venir.
And how would you say we come or we coming?
Venimos.
Good.
To live in Spanish is vivir.
V-I-V-I-R vivir.
Vivir.
You might know this from Viva la Revolución.
You might have heard that somewhere, long live the revolution, viva la revolution, or you might have even heard Viva Las Vegas Long live Las Vegas Vivir to live.
How do you say I live?
Vivo.
Here in Spanish is a qui or aca.
Aqui in Spain and Aca in Latin America.
Everybody understands both.
It's an extremely common word, so you don't have to worry.
Aki or aka.
So I live here
Vivo aquí.
Good.
I don't live here.
No vivo aquí.
Good.
But he lives here.
And let's stress that because we're contrasting.
Pero él vive aquí.
Good.
Let's make it all together.
I don't live here, but he lives here.
Good.
And don't be afraid to try the soft B.
If it's too difficult, then it's not a problem that you pronounce the v.
Maybe you want to pronounce the ver at the beginning and then see what happens.
But the more you pronounce like how people are speaking around you, the more you understand.
To know is.
Saber.
This is a B.
It's a B.
Saber.
This is a B.
So you're not gonna pronounce a V.
Saber.
So we have bivir to live.
We need to open up that association of the letter V to include that soft B.
Maybe you look up the word in the dictionary for summer.
which is verano or verano.
Now if you just program your mind with verano, maybe you won't get it when you hear verano.
So it always makes sense to pronounce the words the way people around you are pronouncing.
So if you are practicing Spanish with Colombians, take their accent.
If you are practicing with people from Rio de la Plata, Buenos Aires, Montevideo who have kind of particular accent, take that accent as well.
If you're practicing with people from Madrid, take their accent.
The more you speak like the people you're listening to, the easier you understand.
Vivir to live.
How is we live?
Vivimos.
There we have the I popping up.
Bivimos.
But for the other versions we're gonna have the e.
So he lives.
Some vow how many you're making there
Bibir the A is correct, but you changed the beginning to match that a B.
Good.
Bibe.
Before you said Bebe
So you must consciously take off that ending, see what you're left with, biv, and put on your air.
Good.
They live, or you guys
Viven.
They live here.
Viven aquí.
Viven aquí, viven acá.
The word for where is donde?
Donde.
So how do you say where do they live?
Dontevin.
I want to know where they live.
Good.
Entender is to understand.
Entender.
We said we can use comprehender as well, which might be easy to remember, but entender is much more common.
How do you say I understand?
Entiendo.
He understands
Why doesn't he understand?
Good.
How do you think you would say we understand?
So for er verbs we have emos.
So this is the only difference in the entire language between er verbs and er verbs.
For everything else they are exactly the same.
But for we in the present tense we get imos and demos.
Vivir vivimos.
Benir benimos.
Preferir preferimos.
And then for air verbs emos.
Entender, entendemos.
Perder, which we said was to lose.
So how do you say we lose?
Perdemos.
Good.
The word for always in Spanish is siempre.
Siempre.
So how would you say we always lose?
Yeah, you can put the siempre before or afterwards.
Siempre perdemos.
We always lose.